okay so the final episode of She-Hulk is
now here and the new entry is packed
with Easter eggs hidden details and a
lot of things you missed throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the entire thing and also giving our
review on the series bull spoilers ahead
and with this being the finale I don't
even want to tease what's coming in the
intro if you've been with us throughout
the journey then please hit the Thumbs
Up Button one last time and don't forget
to subscribe our videos like this every
day by the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into She-Hulk episode
9.
[Music]
now last time we saw Jen attending the
gala that was gonna give her a lawyer of
the air award turns out this was
basically just a participation Trophy
and several of the lawyers got the same
one also female lawyer makes it sound
weird isn't it when when male lawyers
are just called lawyers quickest gun
woke he's gone woke sedatum sedative
now the entry is called whose show is
this and this is a play on Jen saying
earlier in the season just remember
whose show this is this episode kind of
devolves into several characters
randomly popping up and it's eventually
learning this is actually Kevin's show
there's a massive fourth wall breaking
moment in the entry in which Jen
literally goes behind the scenes of
Marvel Studios and this pulls massively
from the comics to create one of the
most meta things that I've ever seen
it's meta now the titles of the episode
say the Savage She-Hulk which was the
name of a comic run starring the
character however the episode is more
like Sensational She-Hulk 12 in which
Jen goes to a film studio and they
suggest things like Marvel zombies and
that she should film stuff as an X-Man
yes that's X-Men it that's what it says
now I also got a lot of Vibes of
Deadpool namely the time he actually
jumped out the comics and into the
Marvel's Rider room the episode is
filled with both wall breaking things
from the off and we open with a homage
to The Incredible Hulk series from the
70s not only does this contain a
voiceover but it also has the don't make
me angry line from the show in the show
this was delivered by Bill bixby's David
Banner to the reporter Jack McGee
interestingly the character's name was
changed from Bruce to David because the
creative team thought Bruce sounded too
gay don't tell Batman that and they paid
a lot of attention to the details here
with Jen and Bruce wearing the same
clothes as the characters had in the
series there's the spinning chair and
the Crosshair going over Jen's face and
we also get a quick shot of the
Abomination we can see his ankle
inhibitor in the photo too with a one of
his face being from a scene in The
Incredible Hulk General also ends up
having to wear one of these ankle
bracelets herself and it stops her from
transforming into She-Hulk we also see
her on a date with Todd calling back to
last episode and see her struggling to
fix a car Sim to how David did during
his first Hulk transformation her eyes
turned green and the transformation
starts where they're tipping the car
over like how Hulk did in the show
there's also a not to Lou Ferrigno who
played the Hulk in the series he also
had a cameo in both Hulk and the
Incredible Hulk and if you want to see
more about him I definitely recommend
watching Pumping Iron where he faces up
against Arnie Lou was a world champion
bodybuilder who done green paint for his
part which we also see here with a
bodybuilder playing out the She-Hulk
form Jen replies the messages from
hulking but these are on the old style
of computer and we also see her standing
over a grave this was a shot used in the
intro and from that it goes into a split
screen of Jen and her face over the
hulks like exactly what they had in the
series now this is revealed to be a
dream I was hoping we'd get we'd get a
nice episode of this and she wakes up in
a cell like the one abomination was held
in here she's visited by Mallory Nikki
and pug and we learn that they've tried
to reach out to Bruce he does return
later on in the episode and there is
potential that we could be getting World
War Hulk down the line which I'll talk
about later on sadly no leader but we do
know that he's coming and there might be
some Clues towards him now though the
intelligence here ruined the event this
is being completely overlooked by the
fact that She-Hulk revealed herself to
be an angry green ranger monster that's
what all the witnesses saw and all that
anyone really cares about there's of
course still a fear that is exists
around the Hulk and even though they've
had this image change with smart Hulk
the public still worry that they're just
waiting to turn angry turns out that's
similar to the Abomination that Jen has
been offered a deal in which he'll have
to wear an inhibited device in order to
leave the cell this is something that
was sort of played upon in the comics
and after the events of world war Hulk
Bruce was confined to his cell before he
was taken out by Red Hulk now Jen's
parents come pick her up and we see her
packing up her stuff with her see you
later litigator after the Hulk out
Jenna's lost her job and just like
episode 2 she's back to being unemployed
Jen was hired by Holloway to head up the
Superhuman law division but she's lost
this now due to the pr disaster she
cleans out her desk and her Pals say
goodbye sadly we don't get any romantic
situations with purg and in the comics
the pair did have a will they want a
storyline through Dan slots run sadly
this doesn't make it to the show and
back home we watched Jen watching
reports on the She-Hulk situation this
reminded me a lot of no way home and
similar to Peter being exposed in the
opening we see as the TV is constantly
running things on her whilst the news
teams around her home these news reports
have all selected the show but whereas
they tended to be positive we now see
how Gala gate has changed things go to
Jen's parents a place that she has to
move back to Judah being unable to find
work earlier in the season her dad
brought a shovel to dig some Graves for
who he was gonna murder he's now
spraying water willy-nilly the man's a
monster now like Peter people follow her
wherever she goes and she slowly starts
to see why it might be good to have a
secret identity as we learned last week
the sokovia records have been repealed
which Jen thought was a bad idea however
we can now see why wearing a mask can be
a big help as it's completely ruined her
life amongst her belongings are several
things that have also clearly influenced
her burst is a poster for Legally Blonde
and one veteran Brockovich which are
both films that are about lawyers
there's also some UCLA belongings which
is the University that Jen got her law
degree at in the comics lastly is
supposed to A Midsummer Night's Dream
which has several plots within it that
all interconnect one part of it is about
performing a play so it's a play about a
play and it's very forth wall breaking
similar to what genders towards the end
code of the scene that was released
online last night and we see Jen and
Nikki piecing together who the
intelligence here are this is riffing on
that Clues Meme and it's also Samia
Andrew Garfield did in The Amazing
Spider-Man 2. I did pause on stuff on
the Post-it notes but alas I couldn't
see any blink and you'll miss at moments
with chicken boy turns out they're owned
by several shell companies and thus it's
impossible to track them down and sue
them I kinda write that the series has
basically been about how Reddit is the
ultimate villain and then the entire
plot for this episode got leaked on
Reddit yesterday so I guess they were
right yet the ultimate villain do not
mess with Reddit Now Elaine comes in
with food and she shows a video of Jen
twerking in college with her friends
tying into how she learned to do it by
the Megan e stallion scene the dance
slot run actually opened with Jen in
college but unlike the video she had no
friends next we see Dennis ripping Jen
apart on the news and in the comics
Dennis buckbakowski was a criminal
prosecutor that she ended up clashing
with at this point Jen vows She-Hulk
never again which once more could be a
call back to Spider-Man Peter sat on his
bed and promised Spider-Man no more
which was also not to the comic run of
the same name the narration in the 70s
theme tune then starts up but she
immediately stops this before texting
Bruce nice little detail on him being
called Smoke Hulk and I did pause the
messages but nothing really there that's
that wild Beyond people asking about TV
shows either way Bruce's A1 in the story
at this point unless she decides to take
a mental health break with a meal
cutting Nikki who sends a twerking video
to the intelligencia site and it ends up
looking like Twitter after the mega
Nissan episode Hulk and DM said to
invite her to an anti-shi Hulk event and
Nikki calls in some major favors with
pug back with Jen she arrives at emeals
to see wrecker outside and after she's
given a place to stay we learn that the
Abomination is actually a guest at the
event love is haiku buck and they the
guy's changed and I'm glad he escapes
he's a he does hold himself accountable
in the end and with pug we watch as he
infiltrates the event and get nods to he
Hulk which was name dropped earlier in
the season there's also questions about
lady Thor which is of course and not to
the reactions to Jane Foster in Thor
love and thunder they basically just
parrot the usual talking points online
that uh YouTubers say and I'm gonna show
this and tell people I got featured in a
Marvel show it was me now Todd instantly
recognizes that [ __ ] pug and
he's super happy that he's there Todd
being involved with this is something we
called all the way back in episode 4.
after we pointed out this voice sounded
similar to the guy who jabbed Jen in the
arm in episode 3. I don't know how this
works with him being the boss but and
also doing the job so either way he's
not fully in charge or he's a patsy
however I do think this is definitely
the same actor so yeah let me know your
three time Below on top of this there's
been several other clues that have made
us become spoilock homes in order to get
to the bottom of it best see on the date
he asked if vibranium could pierce his
skin this of course ended up being the
same material that the intelligencia
agents unveiled when they were spying on
Jen and Josh Todd revealed at the
restaurant that he'd bought a wakandan
spear wakanda forever I I that makes me
uncomfortable sorry Todd revealed that
he'd bought a wakandan spear and this
was then likely melted down in order to
make the needle lastly were his
sunglasses at the gala which looked
similar the guy that she grabbed at the
end so Big W for Kenny spoilers calling
that but we also gotta take some Elves
too I did expect us to get some reveals
with Mallory and Holloway that are
missing from the finale in the source
material Mallory was behind an
organization that was trying to make her
own She-Hulk and with the blood plot I
was expecting her to tie into it too
there was also some stuff with Holloway
where he revealed that he set up the
entire law firm in the hopes that Jen
would Mentor his super villain
granddaughter South Pole he saw Jen as
someone that could look over her and in
turn South Pole would give Jen some
responsibility to stop her constantly
partying we also thought The Leader
might be behind this due to the group
name but nope bloody myth bestowed me
again now from this point Todd goes on
stage and he introduces a special guest
speaker which is revealed to be
Abomination he's just there to be a life
coach though rather than getting into
the She-Hulk hate lots of comments here
I think on how life coaches can often be
misinterpreted and used as a way for men
to Rally around them and prop them up
but that might be me looking into the
scene too deep now Jen enters the event
and sees a meal which makes him change
back into his human form due to it being
against his parole deal he States he's
there just to do the speaking and it
genuinely seems like he's trying to help
the insult sorry intelligent see her out
Jen finds out that Todd is hulking and
he reveals the plan to hire Josh seduce
her make a sex tape clone her phone and
also steal her blood as mentioned in
episode 1 if this gets in the wrong
hands it can have disastrous
consequences as Jen's DNA is
synthesizing more hulks whether they
make more copies or not remains to be
seen But the Marvel universe is filled
with different hulks that all got their
hands and the secrets of how to create
one Todd says that he earned his
superpowers and that they should go to
the best person for the job which is
Marvel doing some social commentary on
discussions based around gender and race
Reese of course had to carry out several
scientific experiments and Todd sees Jen
gaining the powers as being sheer luck
however Abomination did get his powers
through Bruce 2 but the group prays and
worship him because he's a man much to
the disbelief of Jen Todd turns into a
Hulk and everyone just kicks off Titania
breaks through the wall and this is
similar to the entrance that she made in
the court in episode 1. things get even
Messier as Bruce drops in out of nowhere
and he has a sort of rematch with the
Abomination it's not really the level of
the fight in Harlem but Abomination
isn't trying to fight and it just adds
even more of a mess to the entire scene
whilst all this is going on Jen
constantly screams out to the Riders at
this point it breaks the fourth wall to
the point that we get taken to the
Disney Plus app it's one of the biggest
wall breaking things I've ever seen and
we could have the Marvel tab on it and
see she's cutting through that this is
similar to what's happened in the comics
before with her busting out of panels
and pages in order to take over
everything on the app we see the usual
things that we'd see including a
Marvel's assembled episode for Sean Chi
that I don't think is on the tab at this
point now we also have the group stuff
as well and it's such a cool way that
changed up what I thought had been a
pretty lackluster finale he then breaks
through this and lands in a studio which
is when things get even crazier She-Hulk
storms through the lot and goes into the
writer's room much like how Deadpool did
in the comics we talked about before
here we see several Disney icons
including a statue of Walter Mickey as
well as the Seven Dwarves it's around
this time you can catch the QR code and
this will send you to The Sensational
She-Hulk 50. this is also a poster for
Captain America playing on the Uncle Sam
one giving an odd to how this was used
as propaganda back in World War II now
in the writer's room we catch them
discussing making the second season a
dream which is another Dallas the entire
ninth season with that was made null and
void and revealed as a dream in order to
bring certain characters back you can
also see a horn goat in the top right
and though this could be a nod to Jake
I'm telling you it's actually it's
actually Mephisto Mephisto confirmed we
can also catch several classical comics
and this includes the Incredible Hulk
Return of the monster now on the board
we see mentions of gamagoo nanobot
enchantable Hulk and are you sure that's
a real Apple which might be a nod too
are you sure that's a real spell from
Harry Potter might be reaching though
now they are kind of hanging a lantern
on this and they say the entire thing
would be an unexpected twist it's kind
of like when I say a really really bad
pun and then I say it's bad so it's like
it's it's not bad anymore I guess now
Jen just wants to do things her way but
we learned that this is what Kevin wants
they say they'd kill for their lord and
savior Kevin like my Subs do when I tell
them to sacrifice for likes now there
was also a hilarious thing that happened
in the week on my Twitter you know I
like to have a laugh and post on Twitter
for a joke so I said I found Daredevil
unrelatable now because he'd had sex
with a woman couple days later I got a
message saying that lad Bible had taken
it seriously and written a full article
about it I spent most of the weekend
laughing about it and they thank you
guys for letting me become the leader of
the incella gentia now Jane goes through
the Marvel Studios Corridor which is
something that we've seen in real life
when stars like Ryan Reynolds have
visited it there's tons of Easter eggs
here including several life-size Iron
Man suits that were used in the films
this is the Mark II The Mark 42 from
Iron Man 3 and the Mark 7 from The
Avengers is a Thanos resin statue one of
the Hulk and also an Infinity Gauntlet
and several figures Jen goes to see
Kevin and she's then asked to sign a
very lengthy NDA these non-disclosure
agreements open in place so people can't
spill the secrets of Marvel and I guess
it keeps everything under wraps even
though stuff often leaks on Reddit the
mobile security right now they're
probably looking like those guys in the
corridor after that called in She-Hulk
breaks their way through and we hear the
song Big energy by lato reminded me a
lot of the Black Widow hallway fight
from Iron Man 2 and she wipes through
them quite easily Jen breaks into
Kevin's office and we get a scene that's
clearly riffing on the architect one
from the Matrix Reloaded in the film Neo
learned the inner workings of the Matrix
and how freeing people was all part of
the program machines still exerted
control over them and this circular room
is filled with monitors playing several
Marvel movies not gonna list them all as
they're all pretty much there and much
like the architect Kevin is actually an
AI it stands for knowledge enhanced
visual interconnectivity Nexus and it
totally makes sense now why Marvel can
knock out seven different things A Year
Without foggy taking a holiday Nexus is
also a word that's appeared in Marvel at
several points and in Age of Ultron it
was where all the information on the
internet ended up flowing through Wanda
is also an ex's being and Nexus points
in the Multiverse when a timeline breaks
off from a certain point nice little
detail is that the brim above the camera
is also in the show shape of a cap
something that foggy constantly does
when he's promoting films maybe you
could ask him if he's gonna stop
overworking the CGI artists and
hopefully all them delays let people
feel less stressed and we actually get a
nod to this with Kevin saying that
She-Hulk is very difficult to render and
that they'd prefer it if she turned back
to Jen they do this off camera and
there's been lots of Transformations
where they've cut away so they don't
have to spend money if you learn the VFX
artists are now on to another project
and get a little bit of the Black
Panther score with wakanda forever being
the next thing now I did hear from my
sources that a lot of the ending of the
season was re-shot and it's even
possible that they dropped in comments
like this to let us know they're aware
this CGI was a bit off Jen delivers her
closing argument and this massively
touches upon the Marvel formula which is
often used to criticize the franchise as
a whole I really enjoyed this scene and
I think it's one of the most creative
things that Marvel has done since like
werewolf by night now there's Critics on
the daddy issues and general plot
contrivances that make it seem like they
have their tongue placed firmly in the
their cheek at this point Kevin raises
the blood plot with Todd and we get a
tease to what Hulk was doing on sakur
though they don't say exactly what it is
they they do kind of mention that they
were going to introduce his son scar who
pops up later on in the episode she also
asks that Abomination holds himself
accountable and inquires if we can get
another Cameo from Daredevil that's all
we wanted and Kevin is basically a God
that runs the entire thing in the comics
She-Hulk had several conversations like
this with the higher-ups due to knowing
that she herself was in fact a comic
book character she also asks one for the
fans in that are we getting the X-Men
which we don't get an answer to
obviously X-Men 97 is coming down the
line but beyond that Marvel didn't spend
4 billion dollars buying Fox for no
reason Hugh Jackman is of course coming
back as Wolverine and hey lots of things
coming down the line also I'm guessing
that Professor X is back because if
that's Patrick Stewart's final
performance then I'm gonna write I'm
telling it I'm gonna write now turns out
the app is now fixed and though Kevin
says she won't be on the big screen and
imagine that she will pop up in a movie
at some point after Jen is kicked out we
cut back two meals in the daytime to see
the police there Todd is being arrested
and She-Hulk goes out to him Titania is
willingness for her social media but Jen
takes the moral High ground and she
transforms back down and Promises to see
him in court at this point Daredevil
pops up and my man can't stop guide dog
walking his way into
because Titania is on it now too Jen
then goes to a meal and he agrees to go
back to prison for violating his parole
he's finally taking accountability and
though this is sort of undone it does
seem like he's learned wrecker learned
two mate and maybe he's changed now next
we see Jen traveling home and her family
eating dinner with Matt Murdock there
too now quick clear up of last week with
Luke Jacobson in the video I brought up
how mad had gone to him because Melvin
was now in custody a lot of you said
that in dared I will season 3 that he
was found in the freezer but I went back
and double checked just to make sure
there is someone in the freezer next to
Julie's corpse however though it looks
like Melvin this is actually a hit man
guy just looks similar and Melvin was
actually put into custody in season
three now does that mean he's gonna be
back I really doubt it and I think Jay
Gibson was picked for a reason as he
does the same job he also comes from the
comics and with his being the MCU
they've obviously gone with a lighter
tone than they did with the Netflix
stuff now Matt brings up his Law Firm
once more and season three did end with
him reopening this with cookie another
Canon on the Netflix stuff is a bit iffy
but I imagine They're Gonna Keep
elements like this going forward in the
comics Matt did travel to La and he
actually ended up being happier there so
who knows if he's gonna stay beyond the
week or not Bruce end comes out and he
introduces his son scar though we don't
find out exactly what happened with this
he did spend two years on sakar and I
doubt the guy was getting blue but sorry
green balls whilst he was out there he's
also aged up extremely fast because as
we learned from the Grand Master time
works differently on sakur now we know
that world war Hulk is likely coming and
this could time with that now Judith
Thor Ragnarok already pulling in several
parts of Planet Hulk I think they're
gonna skip the main elements of that and
instead do things more in line with
World War hulks for some context Planet
Hulk had the Jolly Green Giant crashing
on Sakura after he was sent there by the
Illuminati worried that he was too
destructive for Earth they thought it
was a peaceful planet where he could
live out the rest of his days but he
found that it was a highly oppressive
Society overseen by an evil emperor Hulk
was forced to be a gladiator but he
caused an uprising in Rebellion that
eventually overthrew the planet's leader
he became the king of the car and he
married one of the mightiest warriors on
the planet Kiera she fell pregnant but
one day the shipy traveled and exploded
killing her and apparently their unborn
child he however did survive and gone to
become Scar and this set up so many
different hulks that we could have down
the line the origin story for his son is
obviously different now with it being a
lot less of a Calamity scar is likely
gonna become the Hulk archetype whilst
his dad is more of a mentor and this
means that Mark Ruffalo can kind of age
out and pass it on World War Hulk was
about him returning to Earth for revenge
and it was an incredible battle between
him and the heroes it's an excellent
comic and I definitely recommend you
check it out if you haven't a World War
hulks with an S was basically a major
battle between two sides on one was the
leader and his mysterious Creation The
Red She-Hulk this was revealed to be
Betty Ross and all the hulks came
together and in order to try and stop
him think this will eventually happen
but we need to have the leader basically
grow in power during the next Captain
America movie titled new world order
this will feature the villain and due to
the name I'm guessing that he wins so
that's where I can see things going on a
top level with Red She-Hulk potentially
being introduced so it levels the
playing field against gen anyway we end
the episode with the male reporter see
I'm not success going over to She-Hulk
entering the court his moment actually
pulls directly from the comics and She
Hulk Issue 7 featured Jen walking up the
steps to the courthouse he promises to
fight people who harm those both in and
out of court and it's it's a sort of
heroic moment still though she's hit
with the sexism and she's asked who
she's wearing to court and guess it's
the same old same old go for the
difficult Diva and from here we go to
the credits over some Missy Elliott and
get new pieces of art this includes
Abomination with his inhibitor on a
chicken so it doesn't set off Ant-Man in
the wars pad something Sim and we see
this as Princess silk feather Romeo
mentioned earlier in the series there's
also Kevin reading She-Hulk issue one
and closure on the tadarch with him
going to jail men sit behind She-Hulk
and we can see them nervously sweating
I'm guessing that time's up guys it's
over now we do get a credit scene with
the entry ending with Wong's springing
meal out of prison earlier in the season
he did say that he'd give him sanctuary
and it turns out he got sucked into
another TV show this is obviously
referring to The Sopranos which I'm
sorry to say I still haven't seen but it
could also be a matter joke on how he'll
be appearing in other shows we end with
abomination asking about the Wi-Fi which
was of course a conversation that also
popped up in the first Doctor Strange
movie now going forward I can see this
project dovetailing into two directions
most of the Disney Plus shows 10 is set
up multiple projects down the line they
often leave lots of things hanging for
example One Division set up Multiverse
of Madness it also set up Agatha coven
of chaos the Marvels and probably some
elements of secret Invasion orkai likely
sets up the Thunderbolts and Elena the
Young Avengers and Cape Bishop in Echo
Daredevil and whatever they want to do
with the Netflix stuff now because of
this I think that She-Hulk is gonna tie
into several things going forward the
first big one is the world war Hulk
storyline and we of course have brought
the Abomination back the leader and
there's lots of stuff linking to sakar
Red Hulk has also been name dropped in
the series and though we haven't had
anything confirmed there are rumors that
Harrison Ford could be stepping in as
general Ross though he hasn't been
announced yet I can also see Abomination
becoming a Thunderbolts member and this
will likely help to reform His Image
he's technically been broken out of
prison and I can't imagine Val tracking
him down a kamitage and getting him on
board as for the leader the
intelligencia in the show is described
as having multiple entities attached to
it and though Todd created it the leader
could be pulling the strings now the
intelligence here in the comics have
several high-ranking members that could
also be coming down the line one of them
is modak who will be appearing in
Ant-Man in the WASP quantumania though I
could just be grasping at straws again
and doing a big Mephisto thing now the
whole group in the comics are super
smart super villains and with them
having so many branches they might all
come together with this new world order
under the direction of the leader he's
confirmed is coming in the next Captain
America and therefore he could possibly
be attached to this in some way or the
other now I want to talk about my
thoughts and feelings on this episode
first and then we'll go into my general
feelings of the series as a whole I
think this was an experience that's
definitely the word I would use for it
but I think the more I think about it
the more I don't know if this is the
direction that they should have taken
now props to them because it completely
blew my mind watching this all play out
and for a first run brilliant yet suck
me in gave constant surprises and I
really love what they did however we did
just have eight weeks of what has turned
out to be a pointless villain plot and
though they acknowledge that the writing
was terrible I'm not sure that that
necessarily makes everything better
still though as for this episode as a
self-contained thing really
groundbreaking in terms of what they did
there was lots of cool Easter eggs in it
it was great seeing Kevin and I enjoyed
it I'm gonna say I enjoyed it but
thinking back about how this tops off
the whole show again I don't know if
they kind of dropped the ball with it
and just skipped out on things that we
wanted to see you know like Hulk's
proper introduction with his son
um actual resolution to the thing with
Todd beyond that the way that it was
written I'm not sure that it's gonna
necessarily deliver on everything that
it's set up to now as I said I did hear
that this was re-shot so it might just
be a case of them realizing that you
know that the way they originally had
the finale wasn't the best way to go
about it and they thought let's just
make fun of it which probably is what
they should have done if they felt that
was the case and yeah it's just very
strange um I think it's going to be
divisive but just on this episode alone
I I enjoyed it and I will watch it again
um but I am coming fresh off this so
when it's this crazy it is kind of
difficult to put your your thoughts
exactly on this episode into words now
answer my thoughts on the series I do
feel a bit disappointed in it overall
firstly I want to talk about the
positive so I'm not just constantly
moaning about it I think that in the end
it does Recapture Dan slots run quite
accurately though it's more of a dumbed
Down version of it it does take Jen and
an arc that but I really thought they
were gonna skip over due to the first
episode tadiana maslani does a really
good job as the character and I found
Jen to be a likable protagonist that
probably has a bright future in the MCU
it's difficult to think of anyone else
playing gen and I think under the right
creative team that there's a lot they
can do with it my main criticisms for
the series center around the structure
of the show it's pacing and how some
episode feel like they've had the bare
minimum put into them so we just have 20
minutes to fill the void until the next
Marvel show I think there's some
brilliant episodes in there like the
Daredevil one but in between there's a
lot of padding meaningless Side
characters that come and go and not much
substance to any of the episodes now
when I've talked about this I've been
told that it's a sitcom to shut up to
sitcom and that's the general format of
it however one of the main things that
people come back to with a sitcom is the
co-stars who have to become a major part
of the appeal they also tend to have the
location stay the same so in things like
friends you have the cafe in the
apartment where most of the situations
revolve around these are the
quote-unquote situations of the comedy
however She-Hulk doesn't do that they
keep adding in new characters and
locations and for me it became difficult
to get attached to it because everything
was changing week to week one division
did pull in elements of a sitcom 2 but
it kept the home and characters all the
same and it worked a lot better in my
personal opinion I think the series also
had a difficult task of having to
appease the direction of the MCU and
because of this you had a weird
structure where things would feel
Standalone but then at the end it'd have
to add something in to tease to the
larger world I do think it was a misfire
hinting to Daredevil back in episode 5
and then dragging him out as it likely
left a lot of fans frustrated and
feeling like they had to come back
rather than them wanting to so yeah it's
a weird one and I think the enjoyment of
the show is down to your expectations
whether you find it funny or not is also
down to your personal pace and what you
think that it did with the characters
for me it did hit from time to time but
there were a lot of Misses I think I
will return to episodes like the
Daredevil and Abomination ones but on
the whole I doubt I'll come back to it
and that's a shame too as I can see the
potential here I really enjoy the dance
slot run and I think this could have
been something special if elements of it
had worked together more cohesively I'm
also starting to think that shows
shouldn't get rotten tomatoes scores
until a season has ended the whole
rating system feels wrong as people can
review vomit and it cause it to look
absolutely terrible now on the other
side of this as well Studios can control
how many episodes I sent out in order to
get good reviews for example with
She-Hulk we got given four episodes
whereas with Loki and Hawkeye we just
got two I think there's a lot of room
for things to be skewed which leads to
these scores being meaningless
especially because they're announced
before things have even wrapped up so
yeah just dropping my two cents there
and obviously let me know your thoughts
Below on the episode as a whole do you
agree do you not drop it in the comments
and hopefully I'll see on the next one
we are in a competition right now and
giving away three copies of door 11
thunder on the 15th of October and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and also
drop a comment with your thoughts and
theories if you want something else to
watch make sure you check out one of our
house of the dragon videos which will be
linked on screen right now lots of
things to talk about it's all heating up
so definitely head over there right
after this now the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
Paul I'll see you in the next one take
air peace